take them out to the ballgame and the
aquarium and the bowling alley the
spears family knows how to do a family
vacay right britney Spears's little
sister jamie lynn posted a video to
instagram on monday showing off some
amazing family adventures with her
nephews 13 year old Sean and 12 year-old
Jaden as well as her two kiddos 11 year
old Maddie and one-year-old ivy we're
talking some serious cousin hangs to see
the fish
sitting behind home plate
tackling obstacle courses
[Music]
go kart racing and even some major
fast-food binges oh and trust me you
guys aren't even ready for the cuteness
that is little Ivy on her tippy toes
pushing around a mini grocery cart did
your heart just explode my heart just
exploded
and just check out Shawn and Jayden
totally doting on their little cousin I
can't it's too much too cute but it
wasn't all smooth sailing for the spears
crew Jamie caption the clip quote
cousins vacay 2019 couple lost credit
cards and a visit to the ER but made
many more good memories that we will
have forever
yeah there's Maddie's sitting in the
doctor's office
oopsie just last week we had a
full-fledged freak out when jamie-lynn
posted this pic of her sister and Kevin
Federline's sons looking all grown up at
the baseball field she captioned the pic
quote everyone had a good time at the
Braves game it seems like the 28 year
old is soaking up all the family time
that she can before she dives back into
work Netflix recently announced
jamie-lynn will be joining the cast of
its new show sweet magnolias and there
have even been some rumors of a zoey 101
reboot
so he's a chaise so how does Jamie feel
about bringing Zoe back she took to
Instagram to let Nickelodeon know she is
hella down writing yo at Nickelodeon
have your people call my people hashtags
zoey 101 something tells me that
jamie-lynn is about to make a major
comeback and I am so here for it of
course we'll be here to break down all
the latest Spears family news so make
sure to keep it locked right here on ET
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]